unser Top-Thema heute Integration auf
Probe neue Chancen für geduldete
Ausländer wie lassen sich die
Herausforderungen bewältigen das
Top-Thema jetzt im ZDF Morgenmagazin
und das betrifft viele geflüchtete aus
der Ukraine geflüchtete aus dem Süden
wieder mit umgehen wer darf bleiben wer
muss gehen klar ist Deutschland braucht
natürlich Zuwanderung um die
demografischen Herausforderungen zu
meistern doch humanitäre
Flüchtlingshilfe der Anspruch auf Asyl
und die gewollte Zuwanderung von
Facharbeitern und FacharbeiterInnen
brauchen ja aber auch zwingend eine
genaue Abstimmung durch die Politik auch
damit Integration überhaupt gelegt
Annette Streicher berichtet
viel versprechend klingt der Name des
Gesetzentwurfs der heute erstmals im
Plenum diskutiert wird Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht das erste große Projekt
der bundesinnenministerin soll im
kernmigranten die schon längerfristig im
Land sind aber kein Asyl erhalten haben
eine Bleibeperspektive bieten Menschen
die am 1 Januar 2022 seit fünf Jahren
geduldet gestattet oder mit einer
Aufenthaltserlaubnis in Deutschland
leben sollen ein einjähriges Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht erwerben können in
dieser Zeit erhalten Sie Gelegenheit die
Bedingungen für einen langfristigen
Aufenthalt zu erfüllen dazu gehört ein
gesicherter Lebensunterhalt
Deutschkenntnisse und der Nachweis der
Identität klappt das nicht rutscht der
Migrant zurück in die Duldung oder wird
je nach Sachlage abgeschoben rund
250.000 geduldete Menschen führen bei
uns ein Leben im Graubereich gut die
Hälfte schon länger als fünf Jahre die
Union hatte den Vorstoß der Ampel heftig
kritisiert erschaffe zusätzliche Anreize
illegal nach Deutschland einzuwandern im
Entwurf steht aber auch dass keiner
profitieren soll der über seine
Identität getäuscht oder Straftaten
begangen hat pRO ASYL hingegen hält das
bewährungsjahr für zu kurz ein Jahr gibt
mir jemand die Chance es sich zu
bewähren also frei von Sozialleistungen
zu leben zu arbeiten Spracherwerb Pass
Beschaffung für zahlreiche Menschen wird
es in diesem Jahr nicht ausreichen
obwohl sie sich bei besten Willen eine
Chance die nicht weit genug oder doch zu
weit geht dieser Abwägung liegt jetzt in
den Händen der Volksvertreter
und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
lamiacador die innenpolitische
Sprecherin für Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Bundestag schönen guten Morgen Freunde
wir haben gerade die Voraussetzung im
Beitrag ja gehört warum eigentlich genau
fünf Jahre und länger wie kommt man auf
die fünf Jahre das war ein richtiger den
wir einfach genommen haben und zwar
wichtig zu sagen wir verkürzen zumindest
diese acht Jahre vorher auch noch eine
Zeit länger als eben diese fünf Jahre
ich glaube fünf Jahre ist ein guter Wert
um zu sagen Menschen haben sich hier
eingefunden die haben sich mehr oder
weniger akklimatisiert sie wissen
halbwegs wie diese Gesellschaft tickt
was vielleicht von ihnen erwartet wird
was sie selber auch leisten wollen und
wie sie sich einbringen können ich
glaube all das zu eruieren braucht halt
eine gewisse Zeit vielleicht auch
Familiennachzug noch noch hinter sich zu
bringen und da waren fünf Jahre vor uns
zu angemessener Wert es gibt einige
Politiker PolitikerInnen wie zum
Beispiel der Innenminister Bayerns die
auch Kritik daran üben an ihrem Vorhaben
da lautet ein Argument am Ende wird das
Ausharren nach einem negativen
Asylbescheid mit Integration belohnt was
antworten darauf ja uns geht es nicht
darum Migration wieder problembehafteten
und vor allem problematisiert zu
behandeln sondern zu sagen wir wollen
Migration endlich konstruktiv begleiten
und endlich erste Zeichen setzen ja er
Bekenntnis zum Einwanderungsland ist es
vor allen Dingen aus meiner Sicht aber
auch gleichzeitig eine Entlastung für
die Wirtschaft denn das wird überhaupt
kaum gesehen es geht ja auch darum
Wirtschaft zu stärken und die
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und
endlich Fachkräfte ja anwerben zu können
beziehungsweise einstellen zu können die
wir eben nicht einfach so abschieben
oder zurückführen wollen vor allen
Dingen darauf wollen wir unseren Fokus
legen aber wenn sie sagen Fachkräfte
wenn wir jetzt über die 250.000 sprechen
das heißt gucken sie dann auch genau wer
hat welche Ausbildung wird das auch ein
Gradmesser sein also der sogenannte
Spurwechsel das ist für uns ja ein ganz
wichtiger Begriff dass wir es Menschen
ermöglichen quasi von einem
duldungsstatus oder gestatteten Status
quasi die Spur zu wechseln relativ
schnell eine Bleibeperspektive zu
bekommen um dann in den Arbeitsmarkt
reinzukommen oder auch schneller
reinzukommen ja dazu gehört natürlich
dann irgendwann auch fort und
Weiterbildungsangebote und schaffen Sie
damit weiterer Kritikpunkt Anreize für
Menschen nach Deutschland zu kommen die
möglicherweise hier eben keine
Daseinsberechtigung haben aufgrund von
Asyl Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention etc
wir prüfen ja jeden einzelnen fallen
tatsächlich jeder einzelne Asylantrag
und Schutz ersuchen wird wird geprüft
und nach der Prüfung wenn sich daraus
ergibt dass wir Menschen Schutz gewähren
und sie fünf Jahre dann eben hier leben
geduldet haben Sie diese Möglichkeit ein
Jahr lang quasi in so einer Art
Aufenthaltserlaubnis zu kommen sich zu
bewähren und das geht übrigens auch zum
Teil schneller als fünf Jahre wenn man
sich eben sehr schnell bewährt sehr
schnell die Sprache lernt vielleicht
sogar schon einen Job hat
Integrationskurse besucht hat kann man
auch schon nach vier Jahren eine
Bleibeperspektive das heißt in ihrem
Vorschlag profitieren sollen davon nur
Ausländer die sich zur freiheitlichen
demokratischen Grundordnung bekennen wie
soll das gehen gibt es dann so eine Art
gesinnungs-test oder wie muss man sich
das vorstellen ich glaube also was heißt
ich glaube es geht natürlich darum wir
fragen niemanden direkt danach ab ob man
jetzt irgendwie ein Amt oder ein Eid
ablegt darum geht es nicht aber
natürlich geht es um ein Bekenntnis
darum dass man sich zu dieser
freiheitlichen Grund jeder kennt indem
man zum Beispiel bejaht hier
Integrationskurse Sprachkurse zu machen
ihr arbeiten will die Kinder in die
Schule schickt also eine gewisse Form
von Mitwirkung eben erfüllt das ist für
uns tatsächlich die Grundlage weiter
heißt es die Abschiebung von Straftätern
und gefährdern soll konsequenter
durchgesetzt werden das hören wir seit
vielen Jahren wie soll das denn
funktionieren insbesondere auch mit
denen die keine Papiere haben genau die
Frage der Identitätsfeststellung und der
passbeschaffung die ist ja zum Beispiel
bei syrischen geflüchteten gar nicht so
einfach wie sie ja dann damit in die
Botschaft zwingen müssen wo sie
eigentlich nicht hin wollen weil sie ja
von dem Regime geflohen sind das wollen
wir in der Tat in einem nächsten Schritt
erleichtern da sind wir auch dran und
reden genau über diese Frage es geht
natürlich muss es darum gehen in einem
Einwanderungsland dass wir nun mal sind
auch zu sagen wir wollen Migration und
Einwanderung fördern und Menschen die
die im Schutz brauchen aufnehmen also
auch positiv konnotieren und positiv
begleiten und gleichzeitig Menschen die
das missbrauchen wollen aber auch
deutlich eine Absage zu machen und genau
darum muss es natürlich gehen und genau
das werden wir in den nächsten
gesetzespaketen auch berück heute
startet ich habe vorhin schon darauf
hingewiesen in Nürnberg auch eine große
Konferenz beim Bundesamt für Migration
sie nehmen da morgen an einer Diskussion
teil die da heiß gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt stärken Bedrohungen
gemeinsam entgegentreten wie wollen sie
die Bevölkerung bei ich sag mal
steigenden Energiepreisen Wohnungsmangel
Bildungsmisere Inflation wie wollen sie
den Zusammenhalt stärken bei Zuwanderung
wo er einige schon auch kritisch sind
wenn es nicht um Fachkräfte ausgerechnet
geht ich glaube das ist genau das
Problem dass wir das so framen oder so
so ja diese Geschichte so erzählen als
würde die migrationsbewegung jetzt auch
noch die nächste Krise auslösen das ist
ja das diese Geschichte die wir
irgendwie seit Jahren schon hören unser
Ziel ist es zu sagen wir wollen keine
Politik der Angst mehr machen und
Migration immer nur angstbehaftet
betrachten oder gar immer nur aus
irgendwelche Sicherheitsaspekten heraus
betrachten und als Bedrohung für unser
Land sondern zu sagen nein Vielfalt und
Einwanderung übrigens hat die schon
immer stattgefunden das ist ja eben auch
nichts Neues die wollen wir positiv
begleiten und eben nicht Anreize
schaffen im Sinne von Miss sondern
Anreiz im Sinne von wir brauchen
Fachkräfte wir brauchen Einwanderung und
die wollen wir begleiten endlich und wie
der Titel der Diskussionsrunde auch
schon sagt man kann das eine tun ohne
das andere zu lassen also auf Bedrohung
und Probleme zu schauen und die
Integration trotzdem fördern da mehr
kador in politische Sprecherin von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen vielen herzlichen
Dank heute wird das alles also in erster
Lesung im Bundestag